une motocyclette électrique qui explose
des incendies spectaculaires
ces images du Service des incendies de
la Ville de New York montrent ce qui se
passe quand certains appareils à
batterie au lithium ion sans flamme dans
cette vidéo filmée par un institut de
recherche en incendie une motocyclette
électrique chargée de manière volontaire
prend feu en seulement quelques secondes
y mettre des gaz des vapeurs chaudes et
dans certains cas exploser explique le
chef adjoint des services des incendies
de Toronto cela crée d'importance
d'incendie
en Amérique du Nord la popularité est
grandissante des trottinettes et des
vélos électriques donnent de plus en
plus de fil à retordre aux pompiers de
2021 à 2022 les incendies causés par des
piles au lithium ion ont plus que doublé
à Toronto alors qu'à Montréal ils ont
plus que triplés voilà un exemple de
batterie au lithium ces incendies c'est
ce qu'on veut à tout prix éviter dans
cet atelier de réparation de trottinette
et de vélo électrique de Toronto selon
le propriétaire les accidents
surviennent lorsque les batteries ne
sont pas utilisées correctement un
mauvais chargeur ou une batterie de
mauvaise qualité peut aussi représenter
un danger donc on peut en effet prendre
toutes ces petites cellules on
retrouvait dans les batteries de
l'ordinateur portable dans un portatifs
comme celui-ci
et les soudés soi-même pour former une
batterie de 36 volts 48 Volts pour se
faire une batterie de vélo électrique ou
trottinette le problème c'est que ça
cause pas mal de de problèmes ça peut
causer des problèmes si on le fait pas
dans les règles de l'art
le Service des incendies de Toronto lui
recommande de ne pas laisser les
appareils chargés sans surveillance
d'utiliser le bon chargeur et de ne pas
entreposer un vélo ou une trottinette
électrique dans la maison le niveau
d'éducation par rapport à tout ce qui
est électrique demeure on va se dire
défiant il pourrait y avoir des notes de
sécurité à ajouter pour faire en sorte
que les gens se rendent compte qu'il y a
un enjeu de sécurité les incendies liés
au pile électrique augmentent mais
demeure assez rare compte tenu du nombre
de véhicules électriques déjà en
circulation les autorités rappellent
toutefois que la prudence demeure de
mise et Sandra Williams Radio-Canada
Toronto